bonjour à patrice le retour des rita
mitsouko qui est pas tout à fait pas
tout à fait parce que fred chichin est
décédé à quelques années mais c'est le
retour de catherine ringer la chanteuse
en fait le projet s'intitule plaza
praticiens et ça c'est un projet de deux
membres fondateurs cofondateur en fait
du gotan project qui ont recruté ont
cherché des chanteuses non hispanophones
et qui ont finalement décidé de confier
la tâche à catherine région ils ont
tellement été impressionné qui lui ont
rompu tout l'album en écoute c'est du
tango chansons
là
m
laisse moi
la longueur
c'est très prompt deux choses d'abord
2015 oui mais le temps où j'allais pas
dire que ceux qui aiment à 100 pièces de
l'avant aimé passer d'élections si ces
deux pour ma gestion qui a passé
d'électro j'aurais préféré plus
d'électro et dont j'adore cadeaux oui
mais quand on prend de vienne aurait pu
penser c'est du ce et du tango par
contre 4 entre ge et pourquoi on l'est
on l'aiment parce que sa gouaille aux
lèvres mais parce que les théâtrales et
et apparemment les puristes prouve que
son accent est vraiment à couper au
couteau
moi je ne maîtrise pas l'espagnol alors
pourquoi ce potro fusion ça me dérange
pas trop s'y fit et déjà d'un vélo
flirté avec la musique latine on peut
songer
en un mot rien d'aller les voir jeudi 19
juin au théâtre maisonneuve dans le
cadre des francos c'est un tout on
écoute ses crêtes
mais
m
sochaux
voilà pour le tango ou alors vous
pouviez pas vous en empêcher gênant mais
j'aime ce jeu est un peu de hip hop ok
ça maintenant que j'ai vaincu une trop
grande inconnue à tanger attendait qu
est une grande aventure ge une
romancière et le 27 ans tient surtout du
slam et l'a déjà enseigné ailleurs sur
de longs aussi on parle ce surdoué qui
ne petit blonde revient dans son premier
album hip hop j'ai vu sur nos pas si ce
tournoi était obligé tout simplement
cliquer sur le lien disque c'était le
plus beau livre un album concert où es
tu racontes ordinateurs apple son show
revendeurs de drogue superbike août
treize danseurs mais la musique sied
aussi à la trame narrative parce que moi
une histoire qui peut coûter une fille
que tout avec les mots à la bouche des
signes oui exactement beaucoup de
pittsburgh it et de basse vallée du lot
est un bon capitaine test m piste on
peut s'attendre à être dans le coup de
coeur pour vous oui tout où on se met ça
va on va se laisser aller tiken jah
fakoly règle émanant des ivoiriens
grande star du rugby notamment dans le
cadre d'un procès libertic c'est le 9
juillet à l'olympia et son album son
nouveau disque dernier appel est en
écoute intégrale ici musées français
belga
le bienvenu
non